et maintenant voici tom villa
sow match
or comme tu prends well assurances en ce
moment ouais je voulais une musique un
peu plus un buis viril ouais c'est bien
la semaine dernière il m'a mis jordi
live mais les village people c'est tous
les fantasmes sexuels de thierry
platteau incroyable série ce soir on a
on a tous le lobby normand sur le
plateau assez raide michel onfray et
orelsan manque que michel drucker est un
camembert et on était au complet
florence vous êtes la seule normande 1
du plateau mais bon comme vous crachez
pas sur un petit cadenas on va dire vous
êtes normand aussi florence foresti
c'est la classe c'est la patronne alors
dans un article sur vous j'ai lu
florence foresti après 15 ans de
carrière et une grossesse elle est de
retour sur scène à quand j'ai lu ça mon
côté féministe ne fait qu'un tour non
mais sans déconner c'est complètement
débile de dire après 15 ans de carrière
une grossesse est ce qu'on dira à propos
d'un mec après 15 ans de carrière et
avoir largué sa femme pour une petite
jeune de 20 ans de moins que lui eh ben
il est de retour sur scène et ben non on
ne dirait pas alors florence vous allez
animer l'ailé césar alors vous nous
direz après mais je crois que tout ce
qu'on présentait les césar sont d'accord
pour dire que le meilleur moment eh ben
ça reste le dîner au fouquet's après
non mais j'ai pleinement confiance en
michel onfray michel onfray c'est la
classe c'est le premier philosophe qu'on
reçoit de la saison à part frédéric
lopez veut dire mais
alors michel onfray on a dit vous vous
étiez islamophobe soutien de marine le
pen est maintenant défenseur de dèche
voilà alors à tous les petits branleurs
qui nous regardent qui sont au lycée qui
dix mois plus tard je veux être
philosophe vous avez vu c'est quand même
beaucoup dans merde donc s'il n'est pas
finir comme lui bosser à l'école
[Applaudissements]
votre dernier ouvrage vous avez
collaboré avec mylène farmer alors c'est
vrai qu'à la base on se dit mylène
farmer et michel onfray qui bossent
ensemble
c'est un peu comme christine the queen
et didier barbelivien il ya un truc qui
déconne et puis en fait elle a fait les
dessins de votre livre alors
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
elle a fait des dessins très joyeux
plein de couleur gris clair gris foncé
gris et noir noir brillant noir mat
c'était très très bien c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai non à coup il ya eu un
bleu foncé alors
orelsan orelsan je le déteste non mais
vraiment parce que ma copine l'adorent
et en fait et vous trouve trop beau et
quand ils vous regardent à la télé elle
a dites vous que vous aviez un petit
côté crade excitant alors je te jure que
c'est vrai moi du coup pour lui faire
plaisir j'ai essayé de me laver pendant
trois jours elle a juste trouvé que
j'avais un côté crade tout court mais ça
alors orelsan pour les personnes qui
connaîtraient pas la base des rappeurs
mais maintenant il est comédien est là
vous jouez dans un programme court sur
canal+ qui s'appelle bloqué à l'origine
le titre c'était deux connards dans un
canapé mais c'était déjà le surnom donné
thierry à vivement dimanche donc tout ça
mesdames et messieurs ma mission ici et
de poser les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
posez michel onfray et si vous pensez
que que le fait que vous croyez en rien
est un rapport avec le fait que vous
leviez en normandie
orelsan orelsan en 1998 vous avez était
éboueur est aujourd'hui votre producteur
de spectacle s'appelle olivier poubelle
non mais c'est vrai c'est parce que vous
croyez au signe du destin que vous avez
signé avec lui ou pas
florence foresti votre fille vous voit
partir ont travaillé quand il fait nuit
et rentre avec plein d'argent le matin
c'est ce que vous faites dans la vie
votre
[Applaudissements]
émission
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux